what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another episode of our
beyond omega level series and to be
honest i've been enjoying making these
avatar videos and taking a break from
the usual marvel and dc superheroes
which as much as i love them i'm sure
you guys probably agree kind of wears
thin after a little while so we're gonna
do another one now we've done videos on
avatar aang the series protagonist and
ira will do next week who of course is
definitely considered a fan favorite
character but today we're focusing on a
character that is not as well known but
still insanely powerful avatar kiyoshi
now kyoshi's first real appearance was
in the episode avatar day the fifth
episode of season two avatar the last
airbender but both of kyoshi's parents
were basically criminals her mom was an
air nomad nun that went on the run did
not mean for that to rhyme
and her father belonged to a very poor
family in the earth kingdom and while
kiyoshi was around five years old her
parents basically abandoned her leaving
her with a poor villager who immediately
put kiyoshi out on the street after
initially agreeing to take care of her
so that guy was obviously a dick but
kyoshi was then homeless until being
adopted by an air nomad monk named
kelsen and this guy had basically been
the air-bending instructor of avatar
kook who had immediately preceded kyoshi
as avatar now speaking of that the
revelation of kyoshi as the avatar
following the death of avatar kook is
pretty complicated so this guy belonged
to the northern water tribe meaning that
when he died the next avatar would come
to the earth kingdom and after looking
for quite a long time everybody in the
earth kingdom believed that a friend of
kyoshi's named yoon was the next avatar
and when it became apparent that it was
actually kiyoshi not yoon that was the
true avatar things got pretty messy the
reason for this mix-up was that yoon was
exceptionally good at earth bending so
much so that when kel sang and a master
earthbender named jian zhu basically
found this guy they assumed that he was
the avatar however as time went by and
yoon showed no ability to bend air fire
or water causing some to doubt whether
or not he was the genuine avatar zhan
zhu doubles down on his belief and
becomes yoon's primary trainer while
kyoshi is assigned to become his mate
now yoon fully devotes himself to
training to become the avatar and he and
kyoshi become really close friends and
then everything goes awry when kelsen
reveals that he thinks kiyoshi is the
true avatar after she uses her earth
binding to control the ocean floor and
destroy an entire fleet of ships now
jianzu takes both yoon and kiyoshi to a
cave to convene with a spirit named
father glowworm in hopes that the spirit
will reveal who is the true avatar now
once father glowworm reveals that kyoshi
is the true avatar jianzu leaves yoon to
be held prisoner by father glorym
literally fed him to a mountain but
shortly thereafter kyoshi would try to
escape the earth kingdom from kelsen but
jian zhu murders kelsing before they can
get away so following this kiyoshi and
her friend ranji both joined the flying
opera company which is the gang that her
parents belong to now ranji who came
from the fire nation serves as kyoshi's
fire-bending teacher and the two of them
also fall in love and so after being
attacked by jeon zhu and seeing him
killed by yoon who had long been
presumed dead kyoshi decides to reveal
herself to the world as the avatar now
as for her powers of course as the
avatar kyoshi was able to bend all four
elements earth air fire and water
meaning that she can manifest and
control each of these four elements
however kyoshi does have multiple
abilities that are not typical to all
vendors for instance during her time
with the flying opera company kiyoshi
learned a sub-skill of earthbending
called dust stepping which is literally
just what it sounds like creating clouds
of dust that she can walk on which
sounds pretty badass and which is
impressive because of one of kyoshi's
shortcomings for a long time which was
that she struggled with feats of earth
bending that required her to control
small particles of earth with precision
now what she never struggled with
however was moving around huge masses of
land which she's done some incredible
earth bending in that regard including
like i mentioned earlier bending the
ocean floor as well as throwing boulders
lifting entire buildings splitting walls
at will and digging moats
instantaneously now kiyoshi displayed a
natural adeptness at firebending and
developed her skills even further under
the tutelage of her girlfriend ranji not
only is she able to do all the typical
fire bending stuff but ranji developed a
technique based on dust stepping called
jet stepping which combines elements of
fire bending and earth bending holy sh
now kyoshi also had a natural talent for
airbending and was able to perform many
feats of airbending despite never really
receiving any training now in terms of
waterbending not only could kyoshi
manipulate huge quantities of water but
she could also use her abilities to heal
others using water bending and during
her final showdown with yoon following
his return as a villain she used them to
freeze his heart and lungs killing him
holy sh now during that same
confrontation she also used her powers
to heal ranji who had been mortally
wounded and did this by entering the
avatar state and using water from
underground reservoirs that's badass now
in what was probably kyoshi's most
impressive feat she accessed the avatar
state and used elements of earth bending
fire bending and air bending to create
kiyoshi island now in order to create
the island kiyoshi separated a peninsula
from the rest of a land mass by creating
a fissure deep enough to access the
mantle layer and then using lava bending
to separate the two masses of land
before using airbending to summon a wind
strong enough to move the land out into
the sea that's amazing now by the time
she died at the age of 230 wow making
her the longest living avatar on record
kiyoshi had cemented a legacy as one of
the greatest avatars of all time now
during her time as avatar she created an
elite force of warriors known as the
daily which were basically earth-bending
ninjas used by the earth king to put
down a peasant revolt although this
would muddy her legacy a bit because the
daily were eventually corrupted but even
so being able to train a group that
exercised such precision in their earth
bending like the daily is quite
impressive given that kiyoshi herself
struggled with precision for a long time
but kiyoshi also formed the kiyoshi
warriors an elite fighting force of
female warriors tasked with protecting
kyoshi island and that endured long
after her death and so kyoshi's time as
avatar was also a time of nearly
unprecedented peace that saw each nation
prosper and so shortly after her death
however that peace began to fall apart
and even in her homeland of the earth
kingdom as the earth king proved to be
corrupt using the daily to expel those
who basically opposed him and so what i
also want to do here i want to point out
probably one of the single most
significant abilities of kiyoshi beyond
all of this which is to be a narcissist
the girl named an island after herself
and then named an entire group of
warriors after herself how much of a
narcissist do you have to be to do that
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later peace